thanks everybody for coming to this
mastering the middlegame class it's my
third time in st. Louis doing GM in
residence and today I wanted to go over
oh oh I want to say for those who don't
know I'm Grand Master Eric Hanson from
Canada and today I wanted to go over
somebody else from Canada widely
regarded as the best Canadian chess
player ever his name is Kevin Sprague it
is not my generation and I'm gonna be
covering a game from the past but just I
wanted to talk a little bit about him
because he's not the most well-known
he's been over 60 years old these days
but he's a two-time World Championship
candidate which means you know pretty
much he was in the top ten in the world
or top 15 in the world at a given stage
and the closest the Canadian has ever
been to a world championship the first
time was in 1985 huge it was a Grand
Master at 30 years old which is really
late for chess standards but he seemed
to peak way after and he got knocked out
and then his second chance was in 1988
and I was in Canada it was pretty much
the last time in Canada we had a really
good chess tournament they had the world
chess festival in in east coast of
Canada so in 1988 he had a second chance
and candidates back then so it was like
a knockout format they would have
players playing matches and advancing
advancing advancing until you know they
faced the world champion at the time
which would have been Garry Kasparov by
by 1988 so you played a match against
somebody and he he scored maybe you know
the biggest result in Canadian chess he
won his first match against the player
by the name of Andrei Sokolov he was
this was in 1988 and so Clough was like
a 24 year old
and was number three in the world the
year before so it was a it was a bit of
an upset and so he advanced actually how
they did it back then was you'd play
your match and they tied after six games
three three with one win apiece and they
had tie break games and he advanced to
the tiebreaker games which is kind of
well when you're the lower rated player
when they shorten the time more upsets
can happen so it turned out very very
good for Sprague it and then in the next
round after advancing he got paired
against Arthur Yusupov some of you guys
may know him it was a top ten player in
the role of the time I'm a very very
highly regarded chess player and and
right now a coach and so that was 1989
another six-game match yeah and as I
said this is pretty much the first time
in Canadian had been in this sort of
cycle for the World Championship and he
sprang it was up one and a half to half
in a six-game match and for those who
don't know in the Grandmaster level most
of the games are drawn it just happens
especially in a match so up even a
single game is big because there's a
high probability that's all you'll need
in a six-game match if your ratings were
quite close that that's that's all you
need to advance so he needed a hold for
four games and this was the third game
and he is playing black against the
Yusupov so I wanted to go over this game
to see what happened with would he he
had black in this game so it's
definitely a very very important to hold
with black it's a lot easier to draw
with white so Spragg it playing the
black pieces used to pop white d4 d5
Knight f3 okay this is usually c4 is the
main move but Yusupov decides to play a
bit of a rarer move although a lot of
the times the transposes anyways so
Knight f3 kind of like overprotection
black played c5 and I might seem really
aggressive for a game that
he only needs to draw but it was really
just some opening preparation after
white plays c4 kind of goes back into
normal waters pretty much I mean if
you're playing white and you try to take
the center unless you do something wrong
black can't win it right out off the bat
so white plays c4 here and all the pawns
are as you can see just attacking each
other but then they avoid any
confrontation and sprager plays d6 for
those wondering what happens when the
pawns are like this I mean if black just
took this pawn why would play e3 and it
most likely goes into transposes into
another a chess opening but why it's
probably gonna just regain regain this
pawn and have an isolated pawn position
otherwise if black plays this one white
will take there and after D takes c4
because the pawns being attacked Queen
takes da King takes the blacks King is a
bit worse blacks temporarily up a pawn
but after some move like a foot before
there's a good chance is that white is
gonna recapture it because Bishop e6
protecting the pawn 95 can't really move
that Bishop anywhere and b5 was a very
common chess just way of playing a4 and
breaking down that structure because a
six a six is impossible white can
capture and not pawn is pinned so white
regains upon it's a little bit of chest
Theory but they are not hanging their
pawns for nothing that's kind of what I
wanted to show there so now black 26
pawn takes d5 pawn takes d5 if Queen
takes d5 you're just giving white a free
tempo after 93 so you take the five and
now we're in the tar ash which is a
fairly well-known chess opening and
probably what both players might have
been expecting anyways at this stage
Knight c3 I'm kind of gonna go past the
opening a little quickly here because I
want to get into the middle
but if anybody has a question feel free
to ask 93 96 g3 one thing to note is
white doesn't want to take on c5 yet
because black hasn't developed this
bishop and we don't really want to help
black develop that bishop so if you'd
rather wait for black to develop the
bishop somewhere and then take that bomb
so at least black has spent an extra
move getting it out rather than just in
one go the Bishop finds potentially a
nice square but again this there's some
Theory here as well white white takes
this pawn d5 is not really hanging or at
least it's a gambit line but the players
players didn't really they trusted each
other here so g3 Knight f6 Bishop g2
Bishop e7 castles castles and one
feature of the tarush opening this block
is that you have to be ready to play the
nice lady pawn because white at any
moment could have taken here and that
leaves the d5 pawn standing alone with
no pawn on either side which is isolate
a pawn position which is a position that
most players generally don't like it is
a weakness for the most part it can be
used as a strength but it requires
higher-level handling for the most part
to turn that isolate a pawn into a
strength so it's not the most common
opening because you do suffer a bit but
back then theory wasn't as developed and
Sprague it was really just hoping to
play very solidly even if you had a
worse position as long as he draws he's
happy he's happy to suffer a little bit
white plays Bishop g5 very reasonable
would be to take on c5 now because black
has already spent that extra of
developing it would be very reasonable
to take it but Bishop g5 was played
developing the last piece this is still
probably within theory for both little
players white plays Bishop g5 and now
the rook rooks on the Queen are
connected the rook can go to c1
that's gonna be an open file but why
it's pretty much completed development
and is also threatening something
actually uh all just asks what's why
threatening after Bishop g5 yes that's
right
so that's right you said Bishop yeah the
threat is let me just make a pass Bishop
takes f6 Bishop takes f6 D takes e5 and
white is up a pawn here the pawns not
defended and d5 is being attacked so why
it's why could even potentially win the
second part but that that is a full pawn
so that is a threat now Bishop e6
d take c5 now in this position yeah D
takes d5 happened here there was the
possibility of taking on f6 Bishop takes
f6 D takes d5 and white is still up upon
right now but black has a variation here
and it's important to note that that box
moves Bishop e6 not a six so you didn't
play into the past that I did but black
can play a fairly two or three move
variation here that regains the pawn
with the reasonable position if anybody
can can spot yeah Bishop takes c3 so we
have to take back and Queen eight five
and okay White has doubled pawns when is
up upon but that Queen is attacking both
the pawns very very white has ruined
their pawn structure a little bit these
pawns right here in order to win upon
but that pawn falls then white will just
be left with this isolated pawn on c3
and that's not really a good trade-off
because from the starting position it
was only black with an isolated pawn so
after Queen a5 there's no real way for
white to for the most part protect both
of them so that's why white didn't go
for it because in this you know d5 is
protected so that's that's not what why
did why did he take c5 Bishop takes e5
and now we do have this isolated pawn
position but instead Yusupov showed a
bit of home preparation here and I'll
show you what he did Bishop takes f6
Queen takes f6 G takes f6 you keep your
pawn on d5 but this is a very ugly pawn
structure double isolated pawns on f7
and f6 even though black has the bishop
here here that's just the very crippled
pawn structure so white that's a
permanent weakness as well something you
don't
want to give if you don't have to so
black played queen takes f6 and the
point of this whole variation is white
didn't rate take on f6 for nothing white
as this pawn hanging two attackers one
defender Bishop Bishop takes d5 it's
possible but Y can just recapture with
the with the Queen and the most
important part is that black can't take
this free pawn on b2 because the queen
is attacking the bishop on c5
so instead mm-hmm
Queen takes b2 so regaining the pawn and
now things get a little bit tactical 97
forking the rook and the bishop
blackfoot his rook e to D because it's
attacking the Queen that's winning a
tempo so white doesn't have time to take
that bishop on e6 not that is hanging
it's protected by a pawn but it's a it's
a good Bishop to take off white black
does have the bishop here after all
so after rook da Queen c1 and now at
this time back in 1989 when this match
was being played this was maybe the
extent of how much the players knew this
was maybe a surprise at that time now
it's well known to play this but back
then it was not so clear so the point is
after Queen c1 the Queen's Queen is
attacking the other Queen Queen take c1
rook takes c1 the Queen is also
attacking the bishop so in this trade
the bishop on B on c5 is being attacked
by the rook and white is still
threatening to take on e6 and when I
mean threatening to take it's as I said
it's not winning
that's that Bishop out right but when
white captures that bishop on e6 black
recaptures with the pawn black will have
another isolated pawn and black did
remove the first isolate bond which is
usually a good thing but you'll have
another one which is a positional Trump
for white so Yusupov is known as
technical player place for small
advantages so this was pretty much his
bread-and-butter to get that sort of no
risk position where he's slightly better
so rook c1 Bishop to e7 these days b6 or
whatever b6 is probably played doesn't
really stop white from doing the same
thing as in the game the one thing I'll
say is b6 is played these days because
black wants to shut down White's e-file
buy it by playing b6 whereas spray d2
played there should be 7
it gives white a little more space on
the C file and that Bishop on e7 isn't
as well placed probably not not as
aggressive that's for sure so this is
what happened Bishop e7 Knight takes c6
f 2 x e6 and now we have the position I
pretty much wanted to start from white
and black equal material Knight Bishop 2
rooks five pawns White has an extra part
on the King side black has an extra pawn
on the Queen set Yusupov is in kind of a
must-win situation he has to treat every
game like that
he's a very solid player so he doesn't
win on demand very easily well and then
there's that there's an 8 to pawn right
here isolate upon and there's an e6 pawn
so it's a bit balanced but what's a
little bit better first of all he only
has to let's say pawn island pawn
structures on a 2 F 2 G 3 H 2 e 2
whereas black has three so usually
that's one way of kind of judging pawn
structure it's a bit of an advantage but
it's really not a lot and so in order
for white to win this game you pretty
much asked I'll play black from here if
you trade all the pieces off this this
should be a draw and one important thing
to notice is there's opposite bishops on
the board so if the Knights disappear
the rooks disappear that's that's a draw
even if black was down a pawn
some situations observations have a very
high drawing tendency in the endgame
because they just neutralize each other
they can't really you know contest each
other so there are a lot of times one
was assumed yeah this is headed towards
the draw but Yusupov starts off in this
position showing a lot of technique but
avoiding going directly into an end game
because directly into an end game I
don't think there's enough black has one
weakness on e6 you usually need two
weaknesses they say to lose the game so
white needs to create another weakness
in black position first move rook c4 I
like this move a lot it's very versatile
the rook can go too
one thing to note when there's opposite
bishops like this I think white is a lot
safer on the light squares right with a
light square bishop black doesn't have a
bishop of that color you you can
definitely put your pieces on light
squares and they're not going to be
susceptible to you know blacks Bishop or
pieces as much so look this e4 is a very
safe square but it's not just a safe
square that why it's a good move it can
use easily swing to d4 which puts more
pressure on this weakness and one way to
judge the weaknesses here's a - it's an
isolated pawn g6 is a nicely pawn but II
six in the center it's a lot more in the
open easier for white to attack didn't
need to and it's also on the same color
as White's Bishop which is favorable for
y so this rook is can go here can go
here can go there it has a lot of space
so rook c4 I like to move a lot another
thing it might accomplish is it takes
away the d4 square away from blacks
knight black is looking to trade off
some pieces and that's no longer
available very reasonable alternative
here would have also been III to take
away that d4 square because yeah white
doesn't want to turn off all the pieces
yet we're still trying to extract a
little bit from the end phase of the
in the end of the middlegame so Roxy for
one thing to pay attention to is white
White's really gonna try to restrict
black from having much space in this
game so Rick to c4
Bishop f6 natural move putting the
bishop on diagonal with more squares
towards the center again at some point
these squares might be important so that
Bishop on f6 works good III and these
these moves all these moves there's
probably two or three good moves on all
these positions and white chose what was
comfortable for him that happens he had
a bit of the system I think the main
compass here is don't let black trade
off that weakness on u6 don't let black
trade off let's say the rooks and the
Knights you know white wants to keep
some pieces on the board here but
besides that there might be a couple
ways of going about it
III work c4 these are these are moves
that are just natural moves not based on
calculation but just based on keeping
the tension in the position keeping the
piece on so rook d6
h4 h4 is still similar to the other
moves I've been saying it's a
multi-purpose move it's flexible and it
doesn't really give black any more space
one thing to know is black really
shouldn't bail out something like 95 yes
it hangs upon but some people might be
wondering hey it's opposite bishop so it
trades awesome pieces it's it's still
not good you're down upon and you still
have that that weakness there's gonna be
a one point I'd like to sacrifice this
block it'd be my isolate upon u6 not the
perfectly fine pot on b7 so there's no
real ways for black to bail out yet if
the rooks were off the board you could
do that but the rooks are not off the
board so rook d6 each for this is a
classic move giving the king of a little
more space also maybe that on a good day
you wanted to play Knight to g5 because
in this position maybe the bishop is
better than the knight so white doesn't
mind maybe a capture on g5 which would
open up this this bishop but there's a
few different few different ways another
thing is h4 is nice because the bishop
can go to h3 next and a lot of times
pieces are quite effective when they
have you know behind the pawns rather
than let's say putting the bishop here
h4 gives a little more protection to
that plan and let's gain some control
over the g5 square h6
black didn't want any of that and the
bishop should be better than the knight
in this position because there's pawns
on both sides of the board it is an open
position so all those little factors
take them into account now rook rook to
e4 I think there's a few most very
reasonable over here rook to be one as
well
Bishop to h3 rook to e4 I think white
what is ready to follow up with maybe
Bishop h3 and just putting a little bit
of pressure on black one thing I was
wondering is is there anything wrong
with black just say hey okay this pawn
is on e6 it's on the color of your
Bishop is it move like a five a good
move for black it does protect it it's
affected by two pieces is that is that a
good move yeah the pawn is still
isolated it is off of the light square
but it blocks blocks bishop completely
and white can shift gears and maybe play
on the Queen side but play with the
better pieces there are still enough
pieces on the board that I mean if why
it turns this bishop into a good Bishop
black's bishop right now is like a pawn
so the piece value matters and E 5 is a
consolation you don't really want to do
after black here played rook to da
he didn't play rook e8 which would also
you know defend the e6 pawn how come
black played rook da de is black playing
to defend you six like because it's
pretty clear to me that white is ready
to play Bishop h3 and put you know two
attackers on the e6 pawn black can play
rook e8 right now and kind of be
prepared for that but there was a more
efficient way of defending that weakness
for black which is why black just
ignored it and moved this rook to the
open file yeah
yeah black players work to get an idea
might be the trade rooks make things
easier and also the King blacks King is
ready to go to have seven to defend the
e6 pawn and if the King was on f7 let's
say let's imagine the king is on f7 the
Rakhine have faith isn't really doing
anything facing its own king so black
you know realizes that and moves moves
forward so what happened Rick after it
Bishop h3 King f7 kind of as expected I
was looking at moves like e5 here and
again I don't like any of them there's
not a reason right away then why they're
bad it's just it looks ugly to me and if
white keeps enough piece on board that
Bishop is going to have to that Bishop
is just way too passive wait way too
passive in the long run problem so
it's going to be very hard for that
bishop to find a good diagonal after you
five so black was really resisting
playing it you could play it to try to
hold on but it does block your bishop
and there's and there's no the thing
about this rook on you for is there's no
real way of dislodging in it so as long
as that rook is there or as long as that
square is covered then this Bishop on f6
will be pretty much rendered useless for
the time being so king f7 King G - Kim G
- okay black camp playbook d1 as I said
black might want to trade pieces with
rook to e1 but that's not possible
because new six needs to be protected
the thing about this position is as long
as that pawn is on e6 there's not a real
rush to cash in your chips so to speak
that this point I need to block has no
time to put any pressure on it
White's fully in control here with the
initiative and slowly improving the
position the King not putting the King
on g2 I like because if my king in the
position like this I'd like to ideally
play a move like Brooke c1 that's an
open file that's right
rook v1 that's an open file attacking
the b7 pawn but against any of those
moves as somebody mentioned here rook d1
is it with a check and I have to take
take
kingi - and the rook goes back to d6 and
black is playing defense but he just
traded off a piece I've turned off a
rook that you know this this certainly
doesn't hurt his chances it wasn't
necessarily good trade off for me I
don't want to trade off all the pieces
but that's not possible with the King on
g2 because I have time to take this pawn
with check I don't have time when my
king is on g1 so why white as I said one
of the main rules I think white is
following here is you know
don't let all the pieces turn off yet I
need to create at least another weakness
before I'm willing to trade off into an
endgame so King to Jitsu by the way Kim
G - and King H 2 are both getting off of
the back rank but King is closer towards
the center on on G - so that's there's
not a lot of danger right now with the
King G - so yeah might as well put it
closer to the center at some point it
might have a role black at this moment
just put the rook back to e8 there's not
a lot to recommend you that doesn't mean
it's a really bad position but you just
have to be willing to defend this this
sort of position because yeah if you
give up if you if you at some point get
sick and play play e5 you can do that
Black's trying to resist that just just
to keep that Bishop still as an
effective piece so he plays rook to e8
he says okay white needs to show
something create another weakness
because sure there's rook on e4 it's
very good there's a bishop on h3 it's
very good
but how does white get a third piece or
a fourth piece on e6 I don't think
there's a way I don't think that's
possible
so black well has that defender there's
no need for black to push that pond so
why needs to you know move to another
side of the board or just create another
weakness so these six I think White's
kind of maximized at this point black
sees that just plays rook rook e8 and
says so what rook to c1
that restricts the night a little bit
because if that night moves anywhere we
might be looking at rook csavage Jack
yes so so that's a good question could
black play Knight d7 and Knight f5 and
block that I think what black could try
it but I think the line of thinking was
similar to why black plate age six white
right now could play Knight to e5 check
black is forced to take it because if
you moved the King away I'll play Knight
c4 attacking the rook and also attacking
you six with the rook and the bishop so
let's say the next move rook c6 Bishop
e6 wins upon but the obvious Bishop
takes e5 is playable but I think black
evaluated the bishop is a lot better
than the night let's say the night
blocks at some point it can't happen yet
probably King f6 I think black just
didn't want to give have a knight a
dance bishop position even though I
don't think any of these positions are
lost it's a matter of picking picking
your poison white is better not winning
and still has to provoke a blunder to
win so that this this would've been
playable I do like the bishop against
the the knight of the position so it was
possible but the bishop is still really
good there and and I think black wanted
to to keep the night and keep the
opposite bishop hope a lot because a lot
of blacks chances here as I said if the
Knights are traded off here just
opposite bishops there's really high
drop off probability with that so I
think that's one thing maybe block was
was banking on that may not have been
entirely realistic so looked at Yi rook
to see one rook to be one is also okay
rook e7 rook c2 both players kind of you
know trading a move here
rookie seven defendants b7 defending is
e6 just
a prophylactic move rook c2 same the
rook see - at least now the knight can
roam around a little bit more because if
the knight moves away black doesn't have
the second-ranked
whereas when the rook was not on c2
black could maybe swoop in and harass on
the on a second so still not a lot has
changed both black White's improved
disposition blacks improve theirs but
you know putting putting pressure on
it's still still building up and still
quite unpleasant to deal with so here
black made the mistake that's really not
so obvious I think here really what you
should do is black is play rook d7 or
and just move back and forth that's not
easy to suggest it's not something I
mean as humans we're just not used to
like sit back and and say hey attack me
and show me what you got but that's
that's one of the few things I think
that black can do one one reason why
black didn't do this potential is that
white has an active planner
one of whites active plans well you have
to use the pawns at a certain point
right now whites only pushed one pawn a
certain point you got to commit a little
bit more if you I think almost all the
pieces are well placed the knight on f3
is good Bishop on h3 rook here rook here
is not bad I'm not sure we're a better
square I can't really get there so I
think white is on the verge of playing
g4 and g5 at a certain point if g4 right
now just to show it let's say g4 right
now I think black can play g5 and the
problem here is this bishop is locked in
so not quite ready but it's something on
the horizon because after all this
position is not balanced there's a
there's an extra pawn for white on the
Kings side four against three black has
that extra pawn on the Queen side and
whoever can mobilize that extra pot
probably has the advantage whoever can
mobilize that and it seems a lot easier
for a white to mobilize that extra
than black so I thought something in the
rear view mirror so Rick see - I think
rook d7 should have been played and I'm
still not sure how to win this as white
which is one reason why I like the game
I don't think there is a clear way you
just have to be patient build up your
position keep the pieces on the board
but rook d7 probably I want to play
Knight d2 and I thought I'm gonna
eventually move my I don't think I can
win anything on u6 I'm gonna move this
rook out of the way put my knight on e4
which is your really centralized square
and try to find something else where the
rook but the knight is good on f3 but I
you know I'd have to try something else
so rook d7 nothing really clear to me
but instead black played the move b6 now
the players at this moment they were
probably I think they're around move 30
so they have to play a little bit
quicker there's a decent chance they
might be in time trouble or I didn't see
the clock situation but maybe black just
got a little bit impatient because black
just doesn't have any real active moose
white hasn't more space you know why
it's not doing that great white white
clearly is better and that's just maybe
that bother black black play b6 can
anybody tell me why
what white played after b6 that kind of
highlighted the why was a bad move
well rock on either c4 I'm probably
gonna play Knight to e5 and I'm
attacking the rook in the night I'm
probably going to accomplish trading off
the Knights which is something that's
why I didn't want to do because now you
know opposite bishops there's a higher
and higher chance we're getting into
those bishop and Bishop end games where
it is usually a draw you know block here
why does feel better as long as Y keeps
the rooks but the more trades
closer to the draw especially the
Knights cuz opposite bishops you got to
watch out for
so b6 I'll let you guys take some time
that it's it so let me move my rook back
it's not entirely obvious it's not a big
mistake so it's not some tactic but
white white has some more tactical
possibilities because that knight on c6
is a little bit looser now the pawn
Knight now the rook on d6 is the only
defender of that Knight that's that's my
my hint
I want to also play under the assumption
assumption that if black plays d5 that's
a bit like that's a small victory for YY
would be very happy if we can provoke a
5 as well
rook f4 why we care for that's right
after 10 moves of maneuvering without
many tactical ideas rook f4 appears and
white is threatening the nice
combination of rook takes c6 rook takes
back and 95 and that Bishop you know
cannot capture it's it's pinned now
block normally to get out this pin you
move the King way or you kick the rook
off the problem is g5 doesn't work
white white could Y can take back there
and E 5 is possible but u 5 as I've been
saying it's not a movie really want to
make G 5 here I will play this rook C 4
move that has been suggested but now
this bishop is much worse if you play
workout 5 I'm worried about this move
yeah
now oh but no if I was played probably
rook c4 and on a good day they're gonna
prop try to play baby Bishop about five
Bishop before that looks like a really
nice centralized square for the bishop
and compared to the blacks Bishop on f6
just the big advantage so
look out for black move the king the
other option is to move the knight
problem is there aren't really any nice
square system overnight
you can't move the knight to be four
you're moving at 285 it's just on the
road you can move there as a safe square
but it's not not a good square by any
stretch of the imagination it's not
threatening to go anywhere good and
white is already threatening a checkmate
in one move even after a move like work
see it 95 would be a checkmate if white
at 2 moves but what white still keeps
the initiative where than the Knights
still on a5 not really in the fight so
black decided to play not you know a
bunch of unpleasant choices they're
decided to move the King out again a
really defensive move that might maybe
is better is night da but you know as
you see that it's slowly getting a
little more uncomfortable and at this
moment
maybe now g4 would be a it would be a
good time to play g4 try to play g5 and
black is still under serious pressure
all's blacks pieces are backwards I'll
just say white here can play Knight to
e5 check the King asked to move and then
maybe hop onto this lovely g6 square
where it can always be reinforced by h5
but white is advancing further in that
position there might not be a knockout
blow but block is even more passive so
sad it's a bailout so Rick out for good
move decided to bail out with King g6
I didn't want to clarify one more time
because this is this is a big part of
the game that black really didn't want
to play e5 the black play d5 I could
play Brooke c4 I could also play rookie
4 and what I would probably do myself is
try to get another piece the rook is
there in the meantime to block you for
because I want to keep that pawn on e5
and keep that Bishop locked I mean this
is a good move but I don't want to let
allow block to ever play I don't
necessarily want allow block to play
before I probably play book you for and
maybe here at some point Knight d2 and
bring my Knights at you for so then I
have a outpost outpost on you for and
the nice thing but I'll post on you for
as it keeps that Bishop bad yes yeah
Roxy for work Safari for it loses loses
a pawn oh yeah or 92 so probably work c4
just works as well but yeah I think
white would just put a piece on onion
for like a common thing is when you have
an isolate upon me fives and I slip on
you'd like to trade it off unfortunately
there's no real way to trade it off it's
blocking your Bishop you want to open up
your bishops but if you pump your Bishop
you're putting this pawn on a light
square and if there's any side that has
total domination on the light squares
it's white so efore is not a good move
but if the pawn just stays on you five
well then that Bishop is bad so d5 is
something black was really really really
trying to avoid blocking his own bishop
in yeah so he played king g6 leaving the
rook on out 4 and now we had a
suggestion g4 and that's what was played
and the idea of it is very similar to
position before hand white is actually
threatening to play g5 somebody tell me
why why deciding to play g5 h stick so
so GD v h6 g v h6 g5 bishop takes g5
rook g4 works that's right rookie for
works and and there's the other way
you could potentially do that although
this one is not as good well so anyways
g-51 that is the distract this night
this Bishop away and there are some
variations where black-white can then
play rook takes c6 with 95 check
although there's the much simpler
variation with rook g4 and this rook is
overloaded they can't go to d5 to defend
this Bishop because he's 6 is 8 that's
probably the simplest but yeah the white
is using the majority on the King side
four pawns against three plus this e six
pot is really bad so why it's playing
where the strengths are so g4 after King
g6 now that's an interesting point
though throughout the game white black
has not been able to trade off the
Knights in this position it might have
been possible 95 is finally playable 95
is finally playable and white could have
a couple nice options here you could try
to keep the pieces on play Knight d4
yeah that's right g5 here if we do some
calculation here I'll give you guys a
few seconds to calculate this there's a
lot of pieces being traded off as this
is about to happen
I'll give the start
maybe h6g 586 g5 Bishop takes d5 not a
move here because the knight on e5 is
hanging black and throwing the
intermediate move Knight f3
but then black I mean then white can do
the same thing and throw in G takes f6
which happens to attack the rook black
just recaptures okay we were up and i up
a bishop but black and throwing an extra
check here continued nightly 1 check
King F 1 so now white is attacking the
knight and the rook if white if black
moves the rook would take the knight so
let's say they take the rook their upper
rook but white recaptures on 7 material
is even there's no way for a block to
stop that pot on e7 from queening so a
bit of a tactical sequence there but
anyways the bishop is usually favored
over the night in these positions in
tactics so it's not a surprise to me
that the even without calculating it's
it's it's favoring white so g5 what
happened so black is still not able to
trade off that night and then on c6
isn't that good because it's forcing the
rook on d6 to kind of be passive why it
has not really off any pieces which was
the main guideline restricting black
from having any sort of actor account
active counter play
the war that's a good question
the king could go to h7 the one reason
why black put the king on g6 and not on
g8 was maybe to contest five although a
lot of times it doesn't work
so if g4 if the King goes to h7 here I
think white will play g5 right away and
something similar happened to the game
but as an example let's say white
captures the black captures upon white
captures they have to know this Bishop
somewhere
yeah that's right the tire everything
there's so many recurring tactics a
knight on c6 is really loose let's say
there should be five we had somebody say
rook age four and black and then White's
ready to play rook takes c6 and Knight
takes e5 getting two pieces for a rook
which is generally quite favorable
especially here with really really good
those are really good minor pieces the
knight ambition
so probably Bishop that one would have
to be played which actually ended up
happening but black decide to keep the
King on g6 maybe to fight for that g5 a
little more so Bishop hey what happened
why Bishop a1 well I think I guess I
guess the question is what are some
alternatives I don't think Bishop ace
one is necessarily best but I'm happy to
hear some alternatives to defend this
because I think the whole time this
whole defense has been very unpleasant
it's been very hard for black to get
anything going here so I don't want to
justify Bishop a1 if somebody has
something reasonable here I'm happy to
to look at that this should be one is
like a pass although it's a little late
maybe for that they should pay one was
played
they repeated knows Roxy one fish should
be to Roxy to Bishop a one probably to
get closer to time control where they
get extra time to think
but now blah I'm now White has to figure
out something any suggestions here so
black is on the run here but as I've
been saying there's still this kind of
thing you have to watch out for is is
letting black trade off pieces besides
that a lot of moves here probably work
but don't allow black to trade off too
much h5 check so h5 check is I think a
decent move the one thing about h5 the
one thing about h5 is that now this
Bishop can return back to G f6 and g5 is
not really kicking it out and if let's
say King age 7 then we played g5 we are
at least messing up our pawn structure
of it because let's after take although
i yeah i'm not sure the full that this
might actually be good concretely g5 h 6
g5 Knight takes you saw this actually
but might work for for white which as I
said there's kind of a different way to
play it he was playing very busily this
might actually just clearly win because
the point is white can play 94 next move
and that rook on d6 cannot move but it's
being attacked but that rook moves the
knight on c6 is following
well King at six I can also also knight
of seven king of Jeanette root cafe does
me know it's bad so here black can't
take there so each five is a good book
each five in g5 is a good move g5 is a
good move I was looking at g5 myself but
actually all those moves still keep that
advantage used to pop played a four and
it's maybe a bit of a chicken move but
he didn't see anything clear so he
didn't want to risk let's say you didn't
see anything clear so he didn't want to
mess up what he had going on the
kingside which is still very restrictive
structure so he played a four a four
stops black from maybe playing b5 or
gaining some space it is a bit of a
waiting move it does gain the be five
square maybe a little bit of space I
can't really explain too much further
than that it really is you still didn't
see something really clear anyway to
move that it's non-committal black now
played 95 which is a move I've been
talking about a lot because you want to
trade off is blocked
actually I've heard what is a for
threatening I I thought that first day
for was I shouldn't say it's a tricky
move it was actually threatening
something and I shouldn't have
criticized it I'll give you guys a
minute
they for looks like a quiet move but
it's trickier than it thinks and in this
case I I do suggest looking at tactical
themes here that's right oh so we got
something here
it's not you know I'm not just
completely winning but I think one of
the ideas of ready for is using almost
all White's pieces I have to find a
waiting move here let's say a six let's
say black actually no black would play a
five rook day - and in this position
probably black has to play rook to rook
to d1 because if something like Bishop
c3 some tactics start coming with like
rook rook c4 there's some there's some
tactical ideas here of trying to kick
the bishop out like this where the
bishop has to go to before we can do
rook takes c6 if the bishop goes to f6
we can go g5 and one way or another
White has these ideas of doing work 66
and 95 I think that's I think that's
that's another reason I'd have to ask
him but it's something that's only
possible the recording today - we're
going to see one they just repeat moves
but a four happened 95
does white trade does white trade nights
here or is there an alternative
so what Julian was asking was h5 check
King here rook outfit and white wants to
maybe double rooks
and if Y can achieve that check on AJ
that would be checkmate but I was saying
you know maybe I trade off the Knights
because I've been talking about that the
whole game and if you you should take
the knight back but in case you go all
all for checkmate this g5 moving all of
a sudden this bishop idea one actually
does something
the thing is here this block is actually
if we move this night away and 92 is the
move I've been talked about to go to e4
the problem is there's this move Knight
d3 which is attacking the the rook on f4
and it's also threatening 91 check which
is a worse check so that white is
actually kind of forced to trade nights
91 check it's pretty strong so then take
c5 happened this should take c5 rook f8
it's not entirely the same as before
black finally traded off the Knights the
white has gained the back rank and
blacks King is not very safe at all
I thought when I was looking at this
game I thought okay you know now there
might be some more drawing chances but
it was very convincing rook F fee so
White's definitely gonna keep two rooks
on the board trade off the Knights but
as happens a lot of time when you have
opposite bishops there are drawing
chances but when there's long piece on
board usually one Bishop is better than
another in this case I think if White's
bishop can get on this diagonal that's
probably a better Bishop because blacks
King is kind of running away on those
same colors well as White's Bishop so
why does an opportunity to kind of have
a much better disappear rook D to d7
once the play rook f7 maybe
trade off some rooks and now the mating
white weaves a very nice attacks aren't
from now a bit of a mating attack f4
the bishop back to have six white plays
g5 them automatically black can play
something like Bishop a1 but his rook c7
so traded the rooks or not we don't have
time to take the bishop on you five do
you trade to trade the rooks on c7 here
there's black but ignores the bishop
plays rook c7 and White has the reactor
that move first
yeah rook t2 is played not trading the
rooks are not of the same value and now
black does have to deal without Bishop
on you five hanging black can't play
rook d7 again that Bishop is no longer
covering that it's only covering the c7
square so Bishop c3 trying to gain a
tempo rook d6 and now white might be
threatening that idea that was mentioned
f5 because the pawn cannot capture it's
pinned so this would be a good version
of that
black reacts very naturally here King to
h7 so now have five black the pawns not
pinned g5 is played opening up the
bishop against the pawn and of course
you know there's something like e 5 here
Bishop f5 check it was most likely
meeting that g6 is the only move rook
takes here and well everything
everything is it should be checkmate
checkmate in a couple of moves so g5
first he took once make sense gives the
King more space on h6 but again we see
that same formation on to the dark
spirits this light square Bishop black
still has that weak pawn on e6 and white
is captured towards the center so so far
White's really using that king's head
majority well black played Bishop b4
here and this is my puzzle white didn't
play the right move here but you can
there's a forced checkmate they missed
it I think all of us would miss it g6
King takes g6 Bishop f5 check no matter
where the King goes that's a checkmate
but that's easy to see I think what's
kind of gnarled I'll show you what's
really nasty this is a check this is a
nice one the pawn is pinned and it's
made but King h6 what's the move here
look at it now I'll take on g6 and
that's yeah
it's official move
can't take that bishop because then that
rook on d6 defends the pond g6 in Roque
chair would be checkmate but otherwise
there's no way to stop for a cage a mate
so it's it's it's solvable
I think if white knew there's a win you
would have found it usually but he saw
something else which also works so no
criticism there but this is a nice
little puzzle there Bishop that five is
not really that's you have to really be
calculating it's not something that
comes to your comes to your mind so
easily so that's a force checkmate or
black sacrifices all his pieces maybe
but instead Bishop before rook da King
went back to g6 and now Julian you get a
second chance at setting up how did
white trap blacks King here Bishop g4 is
a good move I'll play what white did I
think a lot of them lead to the same
refers getting the king same same same
idea yeah black played work f7 does
anybody here want to trade rooks
in this case the two weaknesses are
probably the primary six and blacks King
so white has kind of achieved that
although it's not going for that again
no no trading rook h8
and now the idea is clear Bishop g4
Bishop h5 would be a check the king
would run to f5 and we could have a nice
pawn
checkmate on e4 but black has a couple
moves to stop that
so the ECC's are coming which is so he
tries to resist g5
oh I'm sure one thing what's it let's
say Brooke here you trade rooks now you
play rook e8 and after this move Bishop
g4 and there's no way to stop yeah just
an example bishop age 5 check and
checkmate well anyways what happened
there's a lot of different wind so I
don't want to take too much time there
you played you five Bishop g4 still
threatening that checkmate he takes out
forward
and this was his own way of finding a
forest man rook t5 with the idea of
playing Bishop h5 check King will never
build a bishop h5 check is made you did
f ticks III check King g3 and resides
black has absolutely no moves to stop
Bishop h5 check and if you throw in a
couple spy checks I put my king to h3
and no matter what Bishop the h5 this is
going to be made me a next move
so a bit of a tragic end sprang at the
gameplay I lost this game I think he
played a bit too solid there as you guys
can saw the opening and why not and when
ended up losing that match that was the
quarterfinals so that's the closest the
Canadian has been and I think this was
kind of the one of the key games I mean
that's he was winning the match and and
after this he lost it and up losing a
tie breakers but I mean you can't say
too much about anything bad about whites
whites play arrows pretty much there
wasn't a single mistake never really
locked never really had a really good
variation in the game there might have
been better ways to suffer but nothing
nothing nothing promising so I was a
middle game and the resulting end game
that I really really liked by Arthur
Yusupov hope you guys enjoyed it that's
mastering the middle game
you